oh hey and welcome back to my bedroom
white this isn't my bedroom I'm in my
kitchen I'm wearing an apron this can
only mean one thing okay come on down
children today I'm cooking with Charlie
we're gonna be making chocolate brownies
these aren't just any chocolate brownies
this is a super secret recipe passed
down to me from my great great great
grandmother Gertrude MacDonald so if you
want to follow along at home and make
Gertrude brownies here is everything you
are going to need two ounces of dark
chocolates six ounces of milk chocolates
3/4 cup of unsalted butter two and a
half cups of sugar two teaspoons of
vanilla extract four large eggs 1 cup of
all-purpose flour one teaspoon of salt
hmm one cup of chocolate chips and some
icing sugar
okay let's bake pre-heat your oven to
175 degrees Celsius then turn the hob to
1 put the pan on the hob put some
boiling water in the pan for the bowl
over the water and then put the
chocolate and the butter in the bowl
what is happening this is what happens
when you use a pan that is too small and
a bowl that is too big I was also told
that if you use a plastic bowl
apparently it might melt so don't do
that then stir the chocolate until it's
smooth like chocolate what did smooth
leave it to cool for a bit then add the
sugar ah and the vanilla oh and the eggs
I'm so good at this stir it completely
then add the salt and the flour and
what's that you'll mix thoroughly stir
the chocolate chips if you're feeling
adventurous instead of chocolate chips
why not try some almonds or a banana or
some baked beans or some pasta or some
dirt why not
line a baking tray with butter and flour
pour in the mixture smooth it then put
it in the oven for 25 to 30 minutes
while waiting for those to cook here's a
fun fact did you know that they're ready
wait until it's completely cool cover it
finally an icing sugar if you're feeling
fancy cut it up and then eat it with
your mouth
Wow chocolate brownies did you buy these
in a shop no I made them myself using my
bare hands I am so impressed with
Charlie and his cooking abilities they
smell so good
I know I must eat one right now don't
hesitate tuck in everyone Cheers you've
been watching cooking with Charlie
starring Charlie McDonald as the chef
Michael Aranda as guy with haircut and
introducing Nerds RL as Cassie Croft
cooking with Charlie is brought to you
by eggs find yours inside a chicken near
you you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
okay well that didn't work
join the Macdonald MasterChef